- le confinement est synonyme de garde
d'enfants il faut rester à la maison
pour faire travailler les enfants de 8 à
13 ans donc primaires et collèges la
plupart des enseignants fournissent des
exercices pour non seulement travailler
ce qui était en cours actuellement en
classe et puis aussi revoir un peu les
acquis aussi bien français que les
mathématiques
on utilise donc pour les faire
travailler les ressources qui sont
fournies par les enseignants les cours
du cned aussi et puis c'est un peu
forcément la débrouille on instaurait
aussi un rythme à la maison pour
maintenir des moments précis de travail
travail le matin activités plutôt manuel
l'après midi et puis bien sûr aussi
garder un rythme donc le coucher on
garde à peu près le même que celui de la
période de l'école pour pas trop
déboussolés les enfants qui ont toujours
forcément aussi à plein plein de
questions sur la situation actuelle
il faut pas les sur angoisses et non
plus il faut essayer de garder le
maximum de normalité
et puis aussi cette obligation chez nous
de rester à la maison puisque certaines
personnes font partie des personnes
dites à risque donc les contacts à
l'extérieur se font uniquement par par
téléphone par par visiocom comme la
actuellement et dans cette ambiance
inédite chacun joue le jeu a en tout cas